it was ronnie's birthday
the other day and for his birthday he
went out to dinner with 10 people and i
mean i don't know i don't see any masks
or anything ronnie's going to get
covered but then he was going around
behind my back badmouthing me to
everyone that i didn't get in touch with
him what are you going around
badmouthing me i didn't call you on your
birthday what are you seven years old
you [ __ ] maniac i said to one person
who [ __ ] interviewed me on friday
that's it
i heard everybody robin didn't reach out
to me on my birthday i reached out to
her on her birthday who cares that's
true and i yeah seven years no it's who
now it's who cares but no if nobody did
it to you or rob and they'd be up you
told me you hate your birthday did you
not say that did you not say you hate
your birthday
you know what all right did you not say
to me i can't stand my birthday why
would i come out congratulations that's
not the point okay
anyway ronnie had a birthday party he's
sitting there with 10 people all close
to him no mask they bring over the
birthday cake ronnie now is gonna blow
on the birthday cake oh my god and he
turns to the dude next to him one of his
fancy friends and he goes my fancy helps
right help me blow out the cake i guess
ronnie must be on an oxygen tank he
needed somebody to help him
it was a dinner it wasn't a birthday
party anyway do you want me to call you
on your birthday if you do i'll start
again i mean if that's important to you
i thought you don't i mean the way
you're complaining i was like i thought
the guy doesn't like his birthday he
hates it
i'm fine anyone who don't have anyone
who calls you on your birthday is
reminding you of a day you that you hate
everybody everybody didn't call it's all
good a lot of people called up dude what
texts most people text me you know what
he was going around saying
the main characters on the show didn't
call me
no gary called me like i'm a character
well you said the main characters so you
were talking about
the main characters fred robin
so i was i didn't expect it from fred
i've never said anything about fred i
said i didn't expect it from fred
because he never does that's
that's cool yeah don't be so offended
i'm not offended i'm not offended dude i
just made a comment that's it dude all
heard over there yeah all hurt yeah
let me tell you about me i i'm a good
friend to you all year round you don't
have to worry about your birthday
damn right
i know
here's a ronnie birthday uh song
let me see that [ __ ] it's running my
birthday i know what day it is yeah 72
years old i got this rolls royce
birthday she went to get a [ __ ] copy
stephanie
wanna [ __ ] me in the ass go ahead
[Music]